RUSSIA.
>> HERE ON THE GROUND ON
UKRAINE, MORE PROOF OF VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S ASSAULT ON INNOCENT
PEOPLE.
LET'S GO TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> I WANT TO THANK PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY FOR HIS PASSIONATE
MESSAGE THIS MORNING.
I LISTENED TO IT IN THE PRIVATE
RESIDENCE.
HE WAS CONVINCING AND A
SIGNIFICANT SPEECH.
HE SPEAKS FOR A PEOPLE WHO HAVE
SHOWN REMARKABLE COURAGE AND
STRENGTH IN THE FACE OF BRUTAL
AGGRESSION.
COURAGE AND STRENGTH THAT'S
INSPIRED NOT ONLY UKRAINIANS BUT
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
PUTIN IS INFLICTING APPALLING,
APPALLING DEVASTATION ON
UKRAINE, BOMBING APARTMENT
BUILDINGS, MA ATTORNEY WARDS,
HOSPITALS.
IT'S GOD AWFUL.
I WAS SPEAKING ABOUT THIS WITH
OUR COMMANDER, GENERAL MILLEY.
IT JUST IS AMAZING.
YESTERDAY WE SAW REPORTS THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES WERE HOLDING
HUNDREDS OF DOCTORS AND PATIENTS
HOSTAGE IN THE LARGEST HOSPITAL
IN MARIUPOL.
THESE ARE ATROCITIES.
THEY'RE AN OUTRAGE TO THE WORLD.
THE WORLD IS UNITED IN OUR
SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE AND OUR
DETERMINATION TO PAY PUTIN PAY A
VERY HEAVY PRICE.
AMERICA IS LEADING THIS EFFORT
TOGETHER WITH ALLIES AND
PARTNERS PROVIDING ENORMOUS
LEVELS OF SECURITY AND
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE THAT
WE'RE ADDING TODAY AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO DO MORE IN THE DAYS
AND WEEKS AHEAD.
WE'RE CRIPPLING PUTIN'S ECONOMY
WITH PUNISHING SANCTIONS THAT
WILL GROW MORE PAINFUL OVER TIME
WITH THE ENTIRE NATO AND EU
BEHIND US AND MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE ARE THE
PRINCIPLES THAT THE UNITED
STATES AND THE UNITED NATIONS
ACROSS THE WORLD STAND FOR.
IT'S ABOUT FREEDOM.
IT'S ABOUT THE RIGHT OF PEOPLE
TO DETERMINE THEIR OWN FUTURE.
IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE UKRAINE
NEVER, WILL NEVER BE A VICTORY
FOR PUTIN, NO MATTER WHAT
ADVANCES HE MAKES ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
ANSWERING PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S
CALL FOR MORE HELP, MORE WEAPONS
FOR UKRAINE, MORE TROOLS TO
FIGHT RUSSIAN AGGRESSION.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING.
IN FACT, WE STARTED OUR
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE BEFORE
THIS WAR BEGAN AS THEY STARTED
NEW EXERCISES ALONG THE
UKRAINIAN BORDER, THE RUSSIANS
STARTED IN MARCH OF LAST YEAR.
WE TOOK THE THREAT OF PUTIN
INVADING VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE
ACTED ON IT.
WE SENT UKRAINE MORE SECURITY
ASSISTANCE LAST YEAR, $650
MILLION IN WEAPONS INCLUDING
ANTI-TIR AND ANTI-AR MORE
EQUIPMENT BEFORE THE INVASION.
WHEN THE INVASION BEGAN THEY
ALREADY HAD IN THEIR HANDS THE
KIND OF WEAPONS THEY NEEDED TO
COUNTER RUSSIAN ADVANCES.
ONCE THE WAR STARTED, WE RUSHED
$350 MILLION IN ADDITIONAL AID
TO FURTHER ADDRESS THEIR NEEDS.
TRANSPORT HELL TERSE, ARMED
PATROL BOATS AND OTHER HIGH
PROBABILITY VEHICLES, RADAR
SYSTEMS THAT HELP TRACKING
INCOMING ARTILLERY AND UNMANNED
DRONES.
SECURITY COMMUNICATIONS AND
TACTICAL GEAR, SATELLITE IMAGERY
AND ANALYSIS CAPACITY.
IT'S CLEARLY HELPED UKRAINE
INFLICT DRAMATIC LOSSES ON
RUSSIAN FORCES.
ON SATURDAY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AUTHORIZED
ANOTHER $200 MILLION TO KEEP
MUNITIONS HEADING TO UKRAINE.
I'M ONCE AGAIN USING MY
PRESIDENTIAL AUTHORITY TO
ACTIVATE AN ADDITIONAL SECURITY
SIS SENTENCE TO FEND OFF
RUSSIA'S ASSAULT, AN ADDITIONAL
$800 MILLION.
THAT BRINGS THE TOTAL OF
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE TO $1
BILLION JUST THIS WEEK.
THESE ARE DIRECT TRANSFERS OF
EQUIPMENT FROM OUR DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE TO THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY TO HELP THEM AS THEY
FIGHT AGAINST THIS INVASION.
I THANK THE CONGRESS FOR
APPROPRIATING THESE FUNDS.
THIS NEW PACKAGE IS GOING TO
PROVIDE UNPRECEDENTED ASSISTANCE
TO UKRAINE.
IT INCLUDES 800 ANTI AIRCRAFT
SYSTEMS TO MAKE SURE THE
UKRAINIAN MILITARY CAN CONTINUE
TO STOP THE PLANS AND
HELICOPTERS THAT HAVE BEEN
ATTACKING THEIR PEOPLE AND TO
DEFEND UKRAINIAN AIRSPACE.
AT THE REQUEST OF PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY, WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
AND ARE HELPING UKRAINE ACQUIRE
ADDITIONAL LONGER-RANGE ANTI
AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS.
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES 9,000
ANTI-ARMOR SYSTEMS.
THESE REPORTABLE HIGH ACCURATE,
HIGH ACCURACY SHOULDER-MOUNTED
MISSILES THAT UKRAINIAN MISS
VILS BEEN USING TO DESTROY
INVADING TANKS AND ARMORED
VEHICLES.
IT WILL INCLUDE 7,000 SMALL ARMS
TO EQUIP THE UKRAINIANS
INCLUDING THE BRAVE WOMEN AND
MEN DEFENDING THEIR CITIES AS
CIVILIANS AND ON THE COUNTRY
SIDE AS WELL.
AS WELL AS THE 20 MILLION ROUNDS
IN TOTAL.
THIS WILL INCLUDE DRONES WHICH
DEMONSTRATES OUR COMMITMENT TO
SENDING OUR MUST CUTTING EDGE
SYSTEMS TO UKRAINE FOR ITS
DEFENSE.
WE'RE NOT DOING THIS ALONE.
OUR ALLIES AND PARTNERS HAVE
STEPPED UP TO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT SHIPMENTS OF
SECURITY ASSISTANCE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HEMP FACILITATE
THESE DELIVERIES AS WELL.
THE UNITED STATES AND OUR ALLIES
AND PARTNERS ARE FULLY COMMITTED
TO SURGING WEAPONS OF ASSISTANCE
TO THE UKRAINIANS.
MORE WILL BE COMING AS WE SOURCE
ADDITIONAL STOCKS OF EQUIPMENT
THAT WE'RE READY TO TRANSFER.
NOW, I WANT TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
THIS COULD BE A LONG AND
DIFFICULT BATTLE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL BE
STEADFAST IN OUR SUPPORT AND THE
PEOPLE OF UKRAINE IN THE FACE OF
PUTIN'S IMMORAL, UNETHICAL
ATTACKS ON CIVILIAN POPULATIONS.
WE'RE UNITED IN OUR ABHORRENCE
OF PUTIN'S DEPRAVED ONSLAUGHT
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO HAVE THEIR
BACKS AS THEY FIGHT FOR FREEDOM,
DEMOCRACY, THEIR VERY SURVIVAL.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE UKRAINE THE
ARMS TO FIGHT AND DEFEND
THEMSELVES THROUGH ALL THE
DIFFICULT DAYS AHEAD.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO MOBILIZE
HUMANITARIAN RELIEF TO SUPPORT
PEOPLE WITHIN UKRAINE AND THOSE
FORCED TO FLEE UKRAINE.
IN JUST THE PAST FEW WEEKS WE
PROVIDED $300 MILLION IN
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE TO THE
PEOPLE IN UKRAINE AND
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF TONS OF
FOOD, WATER, MEDICINE AND OTHER
BASIC SUPPLIES TO SUPPORT THE
PEOPLE IN NEED.
OUR EXPERTS ON THE GROUND IN
POLAND AND MOLDOVA AND OTHER
NEIGHBORING COUNTRIES ARE THERE
TO MAKE REALTIME ASSESSMENTS OF
THE RAPIDLY EVOLVING CRISIS AND
GET HUMANITARIAN SUPPLIES TO THE
PEOPLE IN NEED WHEN THEY NEED
IT.
WE'LL SUPPORT UKRAINE'S ECONOMY
WITH DIRECT FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
AS WELL.
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS, WE WILL KEEP UP THE
PRESSURE IN PUTIN'S CRUMBLING
ECONOMY, ISOLATING HIM ON THE
GLOBAL STAGE.
THAT'S OUR GOAL.
MAKE PUTIN PAY THE PRICE, WEAKEN
HIS POSITION WHILE STRENGTHENING
THE HAND OF THE UKRAINIANS ON
THE BATTLEFIELD AND AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS, WE'RE GOING TO STAY
THE COURSE.
WE'LL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PUSH FOR AND END THIS TRAGIC,
UNNECESSARY WAR.
THIS IS THE STRUGGLE THAT PITS
THE APPETITES OF AN AUTOCRAT
AGAINST HUMAN KIND'S DESIRE TO
BE FREE.
LET THERE BE NO DOUBT, NO
UNCERTAINTY, NO QUESTION,
AMERICA STANDS WITH THE FORCES
OF FREEDOM.
WE ALWAYS HAVE AND WE ALWAYS
WILL.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL.
GOD BLESS YOU.
I'M GOING TO WALK OVER AND SIGN
THIS BILL TO ALLOW THE DRAWDOWN
OF THE MATERIALS.
MAY GOD PROTECT THE YOUNG
UKRAINIANS OUT THERE DEFENDING
THEIR COUNTRY.
>> WHAT I'M SIGNING IS -- UNDER
506A-1 --